pour ceux qui se rappellent plus de
Nathalie on va regarder tout de suite un
extrait de son premier moment dans
l'émission Ça rencontre avec Jean
Nathalie regarde ta rencontre avec Jean
c'était fort c'était fort nickel en plus
du physique Jean a su relever des mots
remplis de tendres promesses dans les
lignes de cette grenobloise de 55 ans
qui souhaite à nouveau sourire à l'amour
je suis un peu coquine j'adore faire
plaisir mon partenaire oh bah ça c'est
super qu'est-ce qui t'a plu dans la
diffusion de mon portrait en particulier
ta gentillesse ton regard de façon
d'être un peu des points communs on a
vécu à peu près la même chose c'est tout
alors la famille
la lettre qui aille ouais mais c'est pas
moi
mais c'est ce que j'ai écrit c'est pas
moi quoi alors la vie je suis pas
coquine je suis pas voilà
mais oui elle a raison il faut voilà tu
as eu tu t'es dit ouais je vais mettre
toutes les chances de mon côté oui
d'accord avec toi j'aurais fait pareil
il te plaisait vraiment genre moi c'est
les leçons moi je m'arrête au regard ah
ouais
c'est les yeux toi c'est les yeux quoi
donc à part après le reste tu t'en fous
quoi mais je m'en fous pas mais toi tu
as des beaux yeux merci ma priorité
c'est les yeux c'est je descends pas
plus bas mais c'est les yeux et après je
j'apprends les yeux il a des yeux qui
voilà et après ben j'apprends à
connaître la personne quoi quand tu
avais vu son portrait tu avais craqué
tout de suite bah il y en avait deux je
vais pas mentir il y avait à la fois qui
avait les chevaux
mais quand je l'ai vu quand je l'ai vu
son profil
et quand je l'ai vu moi je l'ai croisé
après car je fais speed dating je l'ai
croisé sur la péniche mais il était il
était plus beau en vrai que la photo
qu'il a envoyé après oui peut-être voilà
Nathalie tu avais une vraie rivale
Laurence tu n'étais pas mal embrouillé
avec elle il y a un extrait qui a marqué
les esprits celui de votre soirée
karaoké
et Nathalie au karaoké il faut pas te
faire chier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai fait pendant 5 ans avec mon
compagnon qui est parti il y a deux ans
donc c'est lui qui m'a appris à chanter
avant que je chantais mais je respirais
pas je voilà et mais après à respirer et
ben après à envoyer les notes quand il
faut les envoyer et Johnny ben c'est
Johnny quoi voilà bien sûr moi Johnny
chante johnny
c'est quoi allumer le feu non il y a
Diego vivre pour le meilleur
qu'on me donne l'envie
incroyable
métier on va regarder rien
je travaille plus là-bas la plonge et je
fais 8h du matin 19h il fait la
vaisselle fraise la journée et avant
j'étais agent d'entretien je travaillais
à la piscine à chatte et à la piscine je
faisais 6 heures 9 heures
je travaille à la piscine à chatte
[Applaudissements]
la piscine olympique
ça ça marche voilà il y a une qui
s'appelle chatte oui comme message comme
c'est ça voilà peut-être passer une tête
donc après je dis je dis où je travaille
je travaille à la piscine de chatte
exactement
la ville de chatte non mais je suis très
important
les habitants les châteaux
des moments compliqués lors de cette
aventure télévisuelle non pas du tout tu
as pas trop kiffé quand même de voir
Jean embrasser alors ça pour moi c'est
le meilleur extrait de toute l'histoire
de l'émission
j'aimerais revenir sur cette extrait de
nous dire ce que tu as il est pas ma
cigarette j'ai envie que Laurence tu
nous parles de ce que tu as pensé à ce
moment-là est-ce que tu t'es dit dans sa
tête même si il y a des vulgarités
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la seule chose que je voulais pas
voir tu me la passes
là tu t'étais dégoûté ou pas bah attends
alors déjà je vais l'impression d'être
transparente quoi ouais voilà ça déjà
j'ai dansé une fois avec lui
heureusement que il y a des autres
monsieur qui m'ont financé et
je pense que si le patron ne dit pas
embrasser votre cavalière il le fait pas
ah ouais ouais et quand il a dit ça
l'autre elle a dû kiffer jubilé ou
jubilé
gibuler voilà elle a dit c'est bon je
vais y aller quoi mais mais en plus je
me suis fait
engueuler par mes collègues on dit
Nathalie pourquoi tu es pas allé au
milieu les séparer j'ai atteint
comme ça
tu crois que je viens pas
elle est jubulle là elle a gagné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exploser quoi vraiment la cigarette
ça a été fini j'ai dit à l'équipe vous
savez quoi je fais plus rien ni de
rentrer de voiture ni de sortie on
refait rien du tout je suis plus là
c'était dégoûté et j'attendais d'arriver
à la ferme tu lui as dit quoi à la ferme
déjà Magalie elle me dit tu tu restes
avec eux sinon moi je sais je monte dans
ma chambre
j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire Magalie
il est venue c'est une personne qui
parle beaucoup et j'adore cette fille
parce qu'elle parle beaucoup avec les
gens qui font les émissions après
j'étais allongé sur mon lit avec ma
cigarette électronique et genre il vient
il me dit tu viens manger avec nous
faire quoi obtenir la chandelle en fait
puis on boit l'apéro si tu veux mais je
mange pas et quand je suis descends
c'était voilà les 20 mots à la minute
championne du monde je sais alors tu as
même décidé donc de quitter la maison ah
bah oui on va pas se mentir ils sont pas
hyper peiné
non pas du tout
même genre il m'a dit Nathalie
t'inquiète pas je vais pas dormir avec
Laurence on va attendre que ce que tu
partes j'y mets James
franchement tu dors avec elle bah c'est
pareil je vais te dire quand on a vu la
langue on peut voir le zizi
j'avais déjà compris donc le bisou
c'était pompeux un peu plus voilà c'est
tout même si tu avais choisi Laurence je
suis pas de la merde je pourrais partir
à pied là je pars
je fais du stop et je me casse
sérieux ça me gave trop les boules là je
suis trop le démon sérieux
[Musique]
c'est une belle journée quand même
je veux une réaction Nathalie c'est
grave mais attends mais c'est même pas
ça tu lui dis les trucs en face je suis
quelqu'un qui parle en face des gens
tu vas manquer de respect déjà
venu comme ça c'était pas prémédité
dans ma douche dans mon lit dehors sur
ton changement fou mais tu fais pas ça
devant moi et quand j'ai vu sa tronche à
côté de moi j'ai toi tu l'ouvres j'ai
juste à faire ça
je m'en vais même pas il vient dehors
dire Nathalie on peut parler rien du
tout rien rien du tout et qu'est-ce que
tu lui as dit à Laurence elle aura rien
tu lui as rien dit rien tu l'as jamais
est-ce que tu leur parlé après
l'émission non pas du tout jamais je
peux pas la blairer mais alors attends
déjà
un truc j'arrive à la gare je me tape 5
heures de train
qui sait que je vois Jean et Laurence
déjà voilà fatigué tu allais prendre tu
vas faire deux heures de course quoi tu
as compris à quel moment que il était
sur Laurent de toute façon je suis
persuadé et je maintiens encore même si
je fais plus partie de l'émission
laurence est arrivé un jour avant moi
d'accord elle est arrivée le jeudi avec
sa voiture moi je suis arrivé le
vendredi elle a pris de l'avance donc je
pense que du jeudi au vendredi ils ont
pas joué au domino et j'en parle
tu crois quoi tu crois qu'ils ont Ken le
jeu mais les gens je suis sûr qu'ils ont
commencé à avoir quelque chose avant que
j'arrive genre des câlins tu vois bah
oui parce que elle s'est dit je vais
prendre de l'avance avant qu'elle arrive
et je suis sûr parce que c'est
qu'un dire on va boire un café genre il
dit bah non on a pas le temps moi je
vais chercher Nathalie et c'est elle qui
a dit à Jean euh ouais ben viens avec
toi comme ça je pense un peu du temps
avec toi ah ouais ouais donc tu penses
qu'il y avait il y avait eu un bail
c'est ça ouais mais je suis mais j'en
suis la première fois qu'ils sont
embrassé là au karaoké
qui sont pas embrassés avant que
j'arrive genre
mais ils ont pas joué aux cartes néo
domino ça c'est sûr tu penses que c'est
sûr ça ah bah c'est sûr ils sont fait
attraper quand ils sortaient de l'argent
mais il est sorti de la chambre de
Laurence ben ouais et la caméra était en
bas de l'escalier
à quelle heure il est sorti la chambre
de Lens ce soir là le premier soir
c'était génial le début j'en sais rien
quand j'ai vu l'émission il sortait de
la chambre tous les deux oh là là donc
là tu t'es dit ouais à mon avis et moi
j'étais chez moi déjà j'y mets voilà
quoi d'avance est-ce que
tu étais vraiment triste ou pas parce
que tu t'aimes tu voulais tu sentais
vraiment que tu pouvais faire quelque
chose avec ce gars et ben coup de coeur
moi je suis 72 de tension à deux et
ma maman m'a dit si tu te mets avec Jean
mais il a pas de cheveux mais tu vas lui
faire pousser les cheveux quoi
parce que c'est trop pour lui si tu
regardes l'émission le gars il fait rien
il fait pas manger et débarrasse pas la
table une année j'ai l'impression qu'il
cherchait plus une femme de ménage une
cuisinière que son corps ensemble les
deux non non ils ont ah c'est fini
maintenant il a trouvé quelqu'un lui il
a trouvé une autre meuf ah ouais donc tu
as vu en fait tu as vu la roue tourne
voilà comme on dit après si la dame elle
est elle est rose avec lui tant mieux
pour lui mais c'est vrai que mon cas je
suis parti j'ai dit j'ai dit à Magali
alors il y en a nounours dans le
Stéphane je l'appelle nounours
le lundi matin je me lève nounours c'est
le cameraman ah d'accord et ouais je les
ai tous baptisé avant de partir et il me
dit le il me dit le lundi matin j'étais
debout à 6h15 j'ai fait le café je vais
voir mon café dehors avec les oiseaux et
bien c'est et il me dit Nathalie il faut
que tu parles il faut que tu parles à
Jean parce que sur les réseaux sociaux
il descendent tu vas pour faire pour
toi-même pour que tu partes la tête bien
ouais je voilà je bois mon café dehors
je suis ma cigarette je suis les oiseaux
qui chantent voilà belle vue et oui il
habite c'est magnifique et genre il
arrive bonjour Nathalie ça va ouais et
toi ça va ouais ça va ouais bon est-ce
que je peux te parler donc on monte un
peu plus haut sur son terrain et je lui
prends la main pose même pas la question
je mens même pas si je peux prendre ta
main je la prends j'ai genre je vais te
poser une question mais il faudra une
réponse toi il me dit ouais vas-y j'ai
franchement comment tu peux dire à 22h30
le dimanche soir que l'équipe que
l'orange c'est plus tactile que moi
donc forcément si tu dis ça si tu as eu
quelque chose avec Laurence et je lui ai
dit si moi je suis tactile mais Laurence
tu la vois même plus tu la vois plus et
donc et donc il t'a dit quoi même
apparaît dans le vieux quand il a dit
quoi j'ai rien
après il a mis laurence est arrivé avec
son t-shirt love ils se font la bise
ils se font la bise
et dans ma tête j'y mets
j'ai dit et toutes les deux équipes sont
on travaille avec deux équipes le matin
et une après-midi ils sont déjà au
courant que vous êtes ensemble donc tu
l'embrasse comme un fou la Guinguette et
là tu lui fais la bise à l'eau donc je
suis monté dans ma chambre je l'ai dit à
Magalie j'ai dit Magali je pars lundi
donc elle s'est occupée du billet tout
ça nana j'y par contre lundi j'ai bien
prévenu alors bien sûr
je vois mon café Nathalie tu veux manger
une tartine non je veux pas manger de
tartines j'ai été au 6e café
[Rires]
on va faire le café j'ai mis le café il
est fait depuis 6h15
ouais mais tu es sûr qu'il
et j'ai dit je m'en vais mais il y a pas
de bisous dans le taxi arrive genre au
revoir tu fais quoi Laurence je te dis
pas de bisous donc il est pas de bisous
elle voulait faire un bisou quand tu es
parti voilà tu as dit toi maintenant
j'ai dit pas de bisous
sois heureux avec Laurence genre il me
dit bah tu es une belle femme tu
trouveras l'amour
et je suis parti puis voilà et le
tableau que je lui avais offert c'est
Anne-Sophie qui l'a récupéré quand même
allez dis comme ça au moins ça tourne la
page on tourne la page il a pas ici il a
pas essayé de te recontacter non
maintenant je suis là il a pas eu le
temps de prendre mon numéro je lui ai
pas donné d'accord voilà alors
tu vas me dire ça reste dans la famille
mais c'est comme si moi je te fais un
cadeau et tu le donnes
Jean-Marie Bigard quoi ça reste la
famille mais bon
ce que je veux dire
que tu le tu reprends contact non non
pas dégoûté mais tu regrettes d'avoir
fait l'émission ou tu es content pas du
tout je regrette pas parce que j'ai eu
des équipes formidables H24 matin du
matin au soir et du soir au matin donc
on peut pas tricher on peut pas mentir
tout ce que vous avez vu à la télé c'est
du vrai est-ce que tu pourrais le
refaire on peut le refaire une deuxième
fois ou pas oui tu peux refaire tu peux
le refaire tu pourrais le refaire après
pouvoir le refaire après après je sais
comment ça se passe peut-être bon il y a
des prétendants qui me plaît bien mais
bon
tu veux pas lui écrire mais pour
l'instant c'est lui de gauche je suis
droite
ma chérie tu as pas trouvé l'amour pour
l'instant non non tu as pas eu aucun
contact bon il y a des gens qui m'ont
écrit donc il y en a un qui habitait à
Bourg-en-Bresse bon c'est quelqu'un
c'est un paysagiste il est handicapé et
tout et tout et Bourg-en-Bresse
et un autre qui m'a écrit par rapport à
l'attitude de gens par rapport à la
Guinguette ça dit ouais et donc lui il
voulait et après j'ai une carte de
[Musique]
maman et d'une fille qui m'ont dit on
vous trouve sympathique on a suivi votre
émission on vous souhaite de trouver
l'amour voilà donc là pour l'instant tu
étais célibataire voilà OK et ben merci
la Thaï on t'aime on va devoir quand tu
veux tu sais que je suis très content de
te voir
[Rires]
de te voir tu reviens quand tu veux on
fait un karaoké tous les deux là alors
maintenant je peux pas parce que il y a
un bail mais tu reviens vers elle
revient un jour on fait karaoké
bon allez on va voir en tout cas merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci